hi everyone in this video we would look
at the concepts behind RNA editing RNA
editing is one type of RNA modification
and we have so far learned about mRNA
capping polyadenylation etc right but
unlike those which does not change the
messages inside the mRNA RNA editing is
a process by which protein coding gene
can change its message and most of the
cases the mechanism by which RNA editing
take place it's by addition or deletion
of a single nucleotide so let's talk
about the possible mechanisms of RNA
editing so RNA editing can occur by
site-specific deamination and this is
augmented by cited in deaminase enzyme
which converts cited in to you reading
so simply convert see to you and there
are other ways such as guide RNA
dependent uracil insertion which leads
to a frameshift and ultimately change
the message in the mRNA so let's talk
about the site-specific deamination
first with an example and then we would
talk about guide RNA dependent uracil
insertion so this kind of example is
found in our GI system we know in our
gastrointestinal system there is VLDL
and chylomicron particles all of these
particles are lipoproteins right that
means they have lipid and protein in
them so one protein component is apple
ipod protein be apolipoprotein b100 is
found in VLDL whereas apple b48 is found
in chylomicron now chylomicron is
secreted from the intestine whereas we
really secreted from the liver an apple
b48
simply means it is just a 40% of the
seeker
of fo b100 so why this kind of
difference offer have you ever imagined
so in order to understand that let's
look at the gene of Apple lipoprotein
this is the pre mRNA and after
processing you would see the mRNA would
look like this now depending upon the
tissue type for example depending upon
liver or depending upon intestine there
would be cited in deaminase activity in
interesting cited in deaminase activity
is high and it converts cytosine into
uracil so from c to you is the change
and we can understand there was a codon
which was marked as CAA and now it is
marked as UA a which is a stop codon so
as a result in the liver there would be
transcription and there was there would
be translation of the whole RNA and the
complete protein would be produced
whereas in the intestine there would be
translation of a partial sequence of the
mRNA as a result of truncated protein
would be produced now clearly we can
understand now the difference between
apple b for p8 and Apple B 100 and we
also understand why Apple B 48 has only
48 percent of the sequence of F of B 100
because there was a stop codon and this
stop codon arise due to a deamination
reaction triggered by cited india- which
is present in the intestine now let us
look up look at the process of guide RNA
dependent uracil insertion now guided
RNA dependent uracil insertion is found
in trypanosomes guide RNA are the RNAs
which guide the insertion or deletion of
residues in a site-specific manner
especially it is found in mitochondrial
RNA zuv trypanosomes now the addition of
you leads to a change in the coding
frame so the frame ships either plus 1
or my
this one however it may be it changes
the message inside the mRNA so the
blueprint is now changed so ultimate
product will be also changed so let us
look at the process in a bit more detail
so let's see let's say this is the DNA
in a trifle trypanosome mitochondria and
there from there there would be a mRNA
produced right now there would be guide
RNA which kind of binds with this mRNA
and it has two regions editing region
and ankle region the ankle region helps
the guide RNA to attach to the specific
site and the editing region works like a
template for addition of new of bases so
in this mRNA there is addition of uracil
but as a result there is a mismatch
mismatch in this mRNA and this kinda
rainy there are specific nucleases which
cut in the site of this mismatch but
further the Leica's enzyme attached you
in this region now ultimately due to
this process there is a shift in the
frame note the uracil which are marked
in yellow as a result you can see the
frame has shifted previously muta mean
as per gene and leucine was encoded by
this blueprint now the blueprint is
totally changed and the final product is
also changed look at these amino acids
these are aspartate cysteine and Ison
using this message is completely
different and the product is also
different so in this video in short we'd
understood that how RNA editing works
after the mRNA is synthesized and how it
is able to change the messages inside
the mRNA and ultimately lead to
production of new products protein
products so I hope this video was
helpful now if you liked my video you
very quick thumbs up and don't forget to
subscribe to my channel please hit the
bell icon for notification and if you
want to join my an academic course use
my code AP 10 to get a 10% discount so
see you then
don't forget to Like share and subscribe
thank you